when Marvel hatched their ambitious plan
for a large-scale cinematic universe
full of comic-book characters they also
kicked off the hottest new trend in
Hollywood tinsel town has universe fever
with major studios all looking to plant
a stake in fertile franchise ready
territory that they hope someday will
rival the MCU superheroes for box-office
domination here are the hottest
properties with the potential to go
Universal Call of Duty video game
adaptations don't always strike gold
we're looking at you Assassin's Creed
but the makers of this popular
first-person shooter still believed they
can turn their prized property into a
successful cinematic universe Stacey
share a producer known for movies like
Django Unchained in the hateful eight
along with former Disney executive Nick
Van Dyke are in charge of Activision
Blizzard Studios they're planning a Call
of Duty film franchise that will have
the same sort of high adrenaline high
energy aesthetic as the game if all goes
well the movies will pay homage to all
the different games in the series from
black ops to modern warfare Sony Marvel
through the spider link
crime-fighting spider your spider boy
whatever you want to call him
Spider Man is back in the MCU fold but
Sony who used to own the web slinging
hero is still planning to feature his
friends in their own movie universe
venom starring Tom Hardy in the title
role will hit theaters in October 2018
another project featuring characters
silver sable and black cap has a
February 2019 when a just don't expect
to see Tom Holland slinging webs in any
of Sony's Marvel films despite some
initial confusion Spidey is an MCU
exclusive kid there's a lot going on
here that you don't understand socks I
should say that Valiant Comics Sony's
shared superhero universe goes way
beyond spider-man's extended family the
studio also has a five picture deal with
comics publisher of aliens and
action-packed movies based on bloodshot
Harbinger and harbinger Wars are all in
development details are sparse but we do
know for sure the bloodshot will steer
clear of superhero conventions in favor
of a classic sci-fi field and this
universe just might have a guardian of
the galaxy in it
dave bautista spilled the beans on
Twitter that he's in talks to headline a
film based on Valiants eternal warrior
title where he'll be reborn as a whole
new kind of hero John wick after a pair
of successful feature film starring
Keanu Reeves John wick is going to
explode in a whole new direction with a
prequel TV series the small screen
expansion will revolve around the
Continental the global Hotel de caters
to the world's hottest assassins but if
you love Keanu in the title role don't
worry Lionsgate has plans for at least
one more movie in the John wick universe
and considering where we last saw him
this hitman has a lot more work to do
before he can hang up his guns whoever
comes whoever it is children hasbro
between the transformers and GI Joe
franchises Hasbro's action figures make
for pretty good action films and big
plans are in the works for a new Hasbro
universe with a team of superhero
specialists in charge of development
Marvel alums Nicole Perlman Jo Coker and
Joe Robert Cole are all on board and
they're ready to reboot GI Joe for a
whole new generation Hasbro Simon waters
promised they'll be blowing up old
conventions to create a more
contemporary Joe saying the world has
changed and I think you're going to see
GI Joe changing with it so while details
are still sparse on Hasbro's plans for
its universe you know it'll be something
new and knowing who has the bobble the
conjuring ed and Lorraine Warren played
by Patrick Wilson and VF Amiga are a
pair of ghost hunters with a room full
of haunted objects in their house which
turned into a treasure trove of movie
ideas when Hollywood realized that the
conjuring franchise was box-office gold
the demonic haunted doll named Annabelle
got two movies out of the deal while
another installment featuring the
terrifying nun is due in 2018 and it
won't stop there
when it comes to the world of the
conjuring director James Wan has
ambitious goals one of the biggest
things I really wanted to do is bring
respect back to studio horror films with
the museum full of haunted objects to
choose from this
one universe that could keep on
expanding for a long time Lego the Big
Bang that spawned this universe came at
the box office
when the lego movie grossed four hundred
and seventy million dollars worldwide
from there Warner Brothers dove
headfirst into the world of colorful
building blocks with Batman and ninja
themed spin-off movies as well as a
straight sequel called the lego movie
sequel as for the universe Lego Batman
movie director Chris McKay says it has a
sci-fi premise in other words the films
are loosely connected by the front
relationship between the lego world and
the humans who build it actually it's a
highly sophisticated interlocking brick
system whatever all you need to know is
that in this universe everything is
awesome hanna-barbera it's only a rumor
so far but the buzz surrounding a
full-on movie universe based on classic
hanna-barbera cartoons is definitely
building starting with a scooby-doo
animated feature film to be released in
2020 if all goes well with Scoob in this
gang Hollywood can go ahead and bring in
a whole world of classic cartoon
characters The Flintstones The Jetsons
Jonny Quest top cat and of course Yogi
Bear whether he likes it or not the same
old thing
Millar world August 7th 2017 was an
important day in the history of Netflix
that's when the streaming giant
announced the acquisition of Miller
world a publishing universe that
includes plenty of hot Hollywood
properties wanted kick-ass & Kingsman
have already been made into feature
films but they may be rebooted on the
streaming service where Netflix plans to
create new original series from existing
franchises as well as any future Miller
world titles some people even think the
Scottish storyteller might give Marvel's
Stanley a run for his money when it
comes to creating the most expansive
universe ever seen on screen hey you
shall shield
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to your YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]